hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute geht es ein richtig einfaches aber
super leckeres winter bisher
ich habe einen orangen tiramisu
zubereitet ja komm hier statt ich habe
einen orangen tiramisu zubereitet und
das fehlt ist das ganze sieht aus wie
eine leckere torte denn ich habe das
ganze in einer kastenform zubereitet
dann kühl gestellt und dann eben
angeschnitten
im innern sie das ganze so aus das habe
ich schon angeschnitten seht ihr hier
und ist es wirklich super fruchtig ich
bereite es aus frischen orangen zu und
da ist noch ein bisschen sind mit dabei
und wer möchte kann noch ein paar
wintergerste dazugeben max probieren
guck mal ich habe hier einen teller
kommt und er darf jetzt mal probieren
kommen diesmal machen was andere strom
die man probieren wir anfangen mit einem
löffel zu probieren nicht probieren
ok dann probiert aber damit die
zuschauer auch wissen wie man das ganze
hier vorne mal die zutaten für das
orangen tiramisu brauche ich 400 gramm
löffelbiskuits vier unbehandelter
orangen eine zitrone 50 gramm zucker
eine zimtstange 400 milliliter
schlagsahne 250 gramm quark etwas
vanille extrakt 400 gramm joghurt dann
nehme ich immer gerne den
zehnprozentigen stichfesten etwas
sonderbar und zum bestreuen nämlich noch
ein bisschen zimt zuerst nämlich jetzt
die orangen der mich bereits gewaschen
und da kann ich jetzt die schale
abreiben kommt es nicht die komplette
orangenschale aber etwa die schale von
einer bis zwei orangen je nachdem wie
intensiv das haben möchtet
die orangenschale lege ich jetzt kurz
zur seite die kommt später in die creme
und die restlichen orangen also alle
vier werde ich jetzt filetieren
das heißt ich nehme hier oben den deckel
weg dann auch den boden und jetzt kann
ich hier die weiße haut entfernen
das ist nämlich der teil der bitte
jetzt nehmt ihr die orange in die hand
und nimmt ein kleines messer und könnte
jetzt hier zwischen den weißen
trennwänden einfach die filets
rausschneiden und ich mach das jetzt
direkt über dem topf denn der
orangensaft darunter trug den möchte ich
natürlich auch gewinnen
mit den restlichen saft können sie dann
einfach noch auspressen
jetzt sind alle orangen filetiert jetzt
nehme ich den zucker da kommt hier in
einen kleinen topf und den werde ich
jetzt einfach bei mittlerer hitze
karamellisieren lassen und in der zeit
nämlich schon mal in oslo biscuit und
bezieht in meine form rein schichten ihr
könnt jetzt zum beispiel eine glas
auflaufform nehmen ihr könnt auch
einzelne kleine gläser nehmen ich habe
zählerkasten form und habe die mit
backpapier ausgekleidet damit ich später
das tiramisu haus stürzen kann
also das wird dann glaube ich richtig
schön wenn man das schon raus schützen
kann und dann scheiben runter schneiden
und dann lege ich jetzt die löffel bist
jetzt einmal an dem boden entlang die
passen auch von der größe her wirklich
perfekt rein ist sich eine kastenform
mit 30 cm länge und natürlich kommen
auch noch welche an den rand und die
werde ich einfach ein bisschen kürzen
jetzt ist der zucker karamellisiert da
muss man auch aufpassen dass er nicht
verbrennt und jetzt lösche ich ihn ab
mit dem orangensaft
da entsteht jetzt gleich kurzen zucker
brocken weil einfach der orangensaft
kalt ist aber nicht schlimm da lässt
sich ja gleich wieder auch hier kommt
auch die zins steigen mit ryan sternanis
wird auch ganz gut passen und ein
bisschen zitronensaft und jetzt lasse
ich die masse hier aufkochen und dann so
ein bisschen sie ruckartig einkommen das
dauert dann so etwa fünf bis sieben
minuten der zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
und die creme zuzubereiten dafür nämlich
jetzt die sahne
die kommt in einer rührschüssel und die
kann ich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
verrühren und dann zwei teelöffel
sonderfahrt zufügen
die sonne setzt steigt die stelle ich
ganz kurz zur sahne so sein
und jetzt nehme ich eine zweite
schlüssel da kommt jetzt der joghurt
rein da nehme ich immer gerne einen
stich westen zehnprozentigen joghurt
dann noch der quark darf ich die orangen
schale nicht vergessen
natürlich etwas von den extrakt und dann
hier auch nochmal etwa fünf teelöffel
seiner partei
und jetzt hätte ich doch glatt rühren
die quark joghurt creme kann ich jetzt
noch unter die sahne heben
es können jetzt entweder mit einem
schneebesen plan machen oder mit dem
teig schaber oder ich mache es einfach
ist bei niedriger stufe in der
küchenmaschine
die orangen massa sieht jetzt so aus ich
habe es jetzt auch abkühlen lassen und
jetzt geht es weiter
jetzt habe ich hier die löffel biscuit
und die werden jetzt so ein bisschen
damit bestrichen
das heißt es kompliziert drüber für
diese schicht gar nicht zu viel
also ich möchte er im inneren das
tiramisu die orange haben einfach mal
was
die masse kann ich jetzt ganz einfach in
die kassen vom 1 ich mache es jetzt mit
hilfe eines beutels damit ich einfach
nicht so viele sauerei machen
jetzt sitze ich hier die hälfte der
creme schon mal rein
da lege ich jetzt eine schicht ein
löffel biscuits rein und weil die frau
nicht ausgereicht haben habe ich jetzt
noch eine andere sorte
darüber kommt jetzt die leckere orangen
schicht natürlich ohne die zim stange
da lege ich jetzt noch eine schicht
löffelbiskuits rein und decke dann die
löffelbiskuits mit der übrigen creme ab
jetzt kann ich die creme ganz vorsichtig
verstreichen und mit der letzten schicht
löffelbiskuits abschließen
das ganze dann abdecken und dann muss es
für mindestens 4 stunden aber besser
über nach gekühlt werden
jetzt ist das dessert fertig ich habe es
einfach auf eine platte gestürzt und das
backpapier entfernt und es geht auch
wirklich super einfach ihr müsst einfach
nur darauf achten dass die löffel
biscuit wirklich nur so hoch sind wie
eben auch der inhalt gefüllt wird also
wenn der inhalt ein bisschen weniger ist
müsse die einfach nur mal abschneiden
damit es stürzen um so einfacher wird
denn ansonsten brechen sie da außen
jetzt könnt ihr zum beispiel ein messer
nehmen dann hebt durchschneiden das
jetzt eben am saubersten aus
ich habe kurz vor dem verzehr noch ein
bisschen darüber gestreut und murat du
darfst jetzt einfach mal probieren
wollte eigentlich probieren aber das
einzige was sie gemacht hat war daher
war die frage was die ein bisschen wie
du selber
nein es ist anfälliger ja ich habe nicht
nur fragen also ist gehalten habe ich
nicht selber gemacht und nicht zu süß
gerne ausgangs in der creme habe ich
nämlich keinen zucker mit drin und
deswegen ist nicht so süß dass ich
glaube so viele menschen die wahl die
wir uns einst auch die orange gelb
ich würde beim nächsten mal also nehmt
es mal als tipp mit würde ich die
orangen masse verdoppeln also wirklich
nicht nur vier orangen sondern mit 8000
mann kann man nämlich da unten auch noch
mal eine orangene zu rütteln
doch im dem orangen ein bisschen aber in
der creme nicht aber die bis konnten
also ich sage ich schob es konnten wir
in österreich aber die wissen ja eh
schon süß genug macht politik einzugehen
aber wie gesagt eine weitere schicht
orange würde ich noch zusätzlich zufügen
beim nächsten mal
das könnt ihr als tipp von mir mitnehmen
es kommt man so ein bisschen soll und
nicht genau
und dann ist richtig gut kommt dass ich
darauf warten wenn die orangen selbst
sehr sauer sind dann kann man klar ein
bisschen zu gast im chance gehabt das
ist sagt orangen 1 murat hat sagt
orangen gesorgt deswegen waren die super
saftig und richtig lecker will ja finde
ich auch falls ihr dieses winterliche
das nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei auf cds - blog.de da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau ich
wünsche euch jeden fall ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und zum guten appetit
und ich finde es wirklich super lecker
und falls ihr das mal irgendwo hin
mitnehmen möchtet könnt ihr es ja auch
in so einer kastenform machen
in meinem back rahmen können das auch
machen oder ihr könnt auch ganz einfach
in süße kleine gläschen machen und eben
proportion schon portionieren sie sitzt
im orangen tiramisu also bis zum
nächsten mal
ich habe quark und joghurt genommen also
eine leichtere variante als tiramisu und
ein echter nicht so schwer
gut gerne tun
ok jetzt schon länger also bis zum
nächsten mal machen wir nicht mal beim
weltrekord mit war schnell essen werde
so schnell ist
das ding mit mir ein wurfgeschoss